messieurs diriez vous que c'est un
véritable danger si la chine obtient ce
statut d'économie de marché et
finalement qu'est-ce que c'est ce statut
d'économie de marché france rustre en
fait la reconnaissance d'un statut
d'économie de marché
ça permet de d'un prix d'un bien situé
d'un prix normal de le traduire en prix
domestiques
est ce que oui ou non les prix
domestiques pratiqué en chine sont des
prix normaux
la réponse est bien évidemment non je
crois qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde est
unanime là dessus mais en fait la
situation aujourd'hui reflète un flou
juridique
on voudrait nous faire croire que la
clause de révision puisque je rappelle
que quand la chine atteint d adhérer à
l'om c'est en 2001 il y avait une clause
de révision qui faisait qu'en 2016 c'est
à dire le 11 décembre là pour une fois
il ya un calendrier très précis on
devait revoir la méthodologie concernant
le calcul d'un prix de revient et
certains juristes de la commission
voudrait nous faire croire que la
redéfinition de ce mode de calcul c'est
quelque chose de strictement technique
finale tu as fais mon gendre mais très
important puisque c'est ce qui va
définir ce qu'on appelle le prix normal
qu'ils aient car pour être clair
fringues pouce parce que nous qui ne
sommes pas économiste prix normal et
prix domestiques c'est quoi ça veut dire
que pour avoir le prix normal que ça
vaut sur le marché par exemple ont
enlevé par exemple les aides publiques
il faut c'est pas tout à fait vous avez
une biche qui n'importe quoi une
bicyclette qui sort de chine à 20 euros
vous l'exporter alors que en fait la
plupart des pays qui sont dans cet
ensemble de statut d'économie de marché
ont un prix normal qui est de 40 euros
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui l'art
est énorme pour la disparité énorme et
donc à une taxe anti dumping qui est
appliqué pour essayer de ramener le prix
normal aux prix domestiques alors
edouard martin quel est le problème
finalement si ce statut est accordé à la
chine
moi je veux rebondir sur ce qui est
effectivement la commission et les
juristes veulent nous embarquer dans un
discours extrêmement technique et
juridique c'est extrêmement compliqué
hier j'ai envie de dire moi je suis un
élu nous sommes des élus
shinzo temps nous avons été élus par les
citoyens européens la seule question qui
vaille à mon sens c est ce que
reconnaître ce statut est la chine est
ce que c'est bon pour les citoyens
européens pour l'europe
oui ou non la réponse est non la réponse
est non parce que on a vu dans le
reportage
un exemple le secteur de l'acier qui
subit actuellement une concurrence comme
jamais une nation c'est à dire que les
choix même s'ils ont alors même que la
chine n'a pas le statut d'économie de
marché il ya déjà une concurrence entre
c'est donc on nous parle souvent du
miracle chinois mais quand même quoi il
arrive à nous produire une tonne d'acier
quasiment au même prix que la matière
première que le minerai qui en achètent
pour pour faire l'acier est
effectivement et c'est là où nous aurons
nous je pense une grosse difficultés sur
les deux plaintes anti dumping c'est
pour que là pour que la loi même s'ils
reconnaissent qu'ils aiment ping il faut
qu'on prouve que le prix effectivement
pratiqués sur le marché local est
supérieur aux prix pratiqués à
l'exportation hors sur l'a6
effectivement ce même prix mais derrière
ça il se cache une la magie chinoise
c'est que c'est à coup de subventions
qu'ils arrivent à maintenir des prix
extrêmement bas donc il faut aussi se
battre contre les subventions publiques
dont bénéficient beaucoup de secteurs de
l'économie chinoise on parle de l'acier
l'aluminium le papier la chimie donc ça
peut avoir un impact négatif sur
plusieurs millions d'emplois sur le
secteur dans le territoire européen et
donc c'est absolument pas pensable comme
puisse se reconnaître ce statut à la
chine